- [Voiceover] Which
expression is equivalent
to the above difference?
All right, this is going to be fun.
So we're adding these two,
I guess we could say rational expressions.
And whenever you add any
expressions like this,
if you add any fractions,
you would have to have
a common denominator
and the same thing is true over here.
And so one thing we can do is
let me actually see if I can, can I,
actually, let me re-write the whole thing.
So three over X squared
plus five X minus 24
minus seven over X minus three.
now instead of you know, what,
I guess the brute force way
is to just multiply the denominators
and say okay, that's going
to be a common multiple
but there might be a
cleaner way of doing that,
especially if X minus three
is one of the factors of this.
So let's see if this is.
So let's see, negative
three times positive eight
is going to be negative 24
and the negtive three plus positive eight
is positive five so this actually can
be factored into X plus eight times,
X plus eight times X minus three.
this is what this thing is
and if this step looks unfamiliar to you,
I encourage you to watch the video
on factoring quadratic expressions.
But what's neat about this is
now we say okay, look,
to have the same denominator here,
we just have to take this fraction
and multiply the numerator
and denominator by X plus eight
so if you multiply the denominator
by X plus eight,
then these two denominators are equivalent
but I can't just multiply the denominator
by X plus eight,
I also have to multiply the numerator
times X plus eight.
And so what does this simplify to?
This is going to be equal to
three over X plus eight
times X minus three, times X minus three.
And then, minus, minus,
and actually, let me distribute the seven.
Minus, remember, we have
this negative sign out front
so it's going to be minus seven,
actually, let me just
write it this way first.
Minus seven X plus 56
over, over X plus eight
times X minus three.
If I was really under
time pressure on the SAT,
I wouldn't probably do all of these steps.
I would try to get to the chase,
cut to the chase a little bit faster
but this is hopefully so it
helps us understand things.
And so this is going to be equal to,
we have our common denominator.
X plus eight times X minus three,
so it's going to be three
and we can distribute this negative sign,
minus seven X, minus, minus 56.
So it's going to be equal to,
let's see, we can write negative seven X
and then 3 minus 56 is minus 53,
or negative 53
and X plus eight times X minus three,
we already established is the same thing
as X squared plus five X minus 24.
And that is exactly,
that's exactly this
choice right over there.